going back to the mind of that guy uh so
confident
no fear at this point
is there a bit of ego in there too yes
like I say no I'm not gonna say I'm
fearful I'm fearless of course This
concerns
that fight I would have to say was
probably the fight that I got nervous
the most walking in because I knew what
that meant that fight I mean everything
for me all my legacy was on the line
because
before I lost the fight though forever
will be number two yeah forever and I
mean bushes is a great great guy great
competitor judicious is very good but
I'm better than him I knew that it's
like he's competing non-stop with them
he's uh he's a great competitor you know
taking nothing out of him he's super
tough very very tough very good he's
probably the best competitor introducer
91 13 times the world championship I won
10. so as a competitor you know he gets
more titles than I do
so but in terms of you know analyzing
the game I consider technically better
than him
so knowing all that everything that I
build all my legacy it's
if I was writing in this match if I lose
this fight I'm forever number two
and none of that is going going through
your mind no I knew I mean it's not at
that moment that I I already knew that I
remember just before you know the
curtains open I'm standing in before
they call my name and I mean my legs
were like
I feel the adrenaline kick in on my legs
and I'm like
you know I'm hitting the legs I'm like
wake up you know get off get adrenaline
off me you know
so it's it was it was intense it was
intense and this was in Rio and that was
in real so my hometown so this is I mean
and you know Rio is is not exactly known
for its calmness in its fans so this is
like wow wherever they hosted the
Olympics
the year before yeah so this is like
I mean this like the whole basically
martial arts Community is watching this
stuff like
yeah I mean is there some uh was henzo
there yeah yeah so people are just I
mean there's attention it's also
I mean I don't know if you felt that in
part but you're also fighting for the
Gracie name yeah
in our hometown the greatest where the
Gracie really is crazy competitor of all
time arguably in the hometown
yeah I mean okay all my family my best
friends my friends everybody watching
everybody there there was a lot of
pressure a lot
so and then
were you thinking that you would be able
to submit him no it's at that point like
I don't predict how the fight will go
that I never did because it is
unpredictable it's I never tried to set
any strategy for any fight I think oh
okay that I did but that was the only
time that I set any strategy into a
fight there was a 15 minutes fight that
and for I said first five minutes I'm
gonna play defense he's bigger stronger
younger I don't want to play his game
and I know he comes in very fast every
single fight he had you know he comes
very aggressive
so my strategy walk into the fight let's
say five minutes I'm gonna play defense
I'm not gonna try to attack I'm not
gonna try to match his pace
I already expected you know maybe I'm
gonna start losing the fight because you
know if he comes in there's a risk of me
maybe getting takedown you know
something happened
I'm like I'm gonna stick to the game
plan
five minutes I'm gonna stop picking up
the pace because then it's 10 minutes to
go which 10 minutes long fight so I
don't need to stop fast but I'm gonna
stop being more aggressive and then
you know try to take him down or put God
you know by then I'm like that's as far
as strategy goes there's no specific uh
stay on the feet were you comfortable
being both bottom and top and this yeah
strategic I'm always comfortable I mean
bottle top I prefer to be on top because
being in the bottom the person on top
dictates the pace of the fight because
he's on top over you so I always prefer
to be on top because I can dictate the
pace I can Implement my own pace
and being the bottom they can Slow Me
Down
so it's harder so if I can choose I will
always be on top
but I think by then I was like is
you know five minutes hit it I'm like
he's pretty big and strong I'm gonna
spend a lot of energy taking him down
I forgot how did it how did it feel
so here you're stepping in by the way
puzzle masks this is old school as old
school as it gets
so calm and relaxed here for people just
listening we're watching the early
minutes of the match yeah so just
feeling it out he seems pretty calm too
he must be nervous too I wonder how do
you ever talk to him you guys are
friends yeah yeah we're friends did he
ever say how nervous he was no we never
spoke about that fight no no
he probably lays uh late at night
thinking about it maybe I don't know
that SOB yeah I mean so you see the
first five minutes you know he kept
I knew what he was going to do in my
study his game his stand-up is most
basic is basic in takedowns uh leg
attacks double legs so you go single
double and he charges in that is pretty
much his
stand-up game so you would try you get
you get a grip yeah that we got
penalized
so do you like to uh use the
do you like to post with your left you
have a right foot forward usually you're
righty right I'm ready but I know he
wants my leg so I'm I'm playing my
stance just because of his game oh you
know all my grips are that the first
five minutes was to kind of try to
neutralize his attacks so he wants to
get your left leg Yeah
uh yeah right there yeah so how hard is
that to stop that I mean he felt pretty
strong
so I'm you know I'm pushing the head
down trying to play with his balance
yeah if if you if you see it there was a
pause
go back there he charged in
there's a pause me standing in front of
him yeah I did that on purpose
what do you mean
just uh it's just in front of him
because you know he tried yeah and I'm
like you fail I'm here
there's a
okay so you could feel the frustrations
I could feel his frustrated his
frustration not be able to take me down
okay so now and this is just
psychological battles and you see me
walking straight into the middle of the
mat and he's circling out yeah see I'm
going very slow I'm recovering and he's
Computing like [ __ ] yeah okay because he
just made a you know effort trying to
take me down he needs to recover
and I mean you you need to recover the
other guys there waiting for you yeah
enjoy do I go for another take down
because this one failed yeah do I need
to recalculate the strategy yeah and he
kept trying over and over again and keep
failing I think that frustrated him a
lot on that fight I fell
I felt him kind of slowing down suddenly
because he was getting nowhere
so we're five minutes in yeah he keeps
so you never got that takedown in the in
the early no
let's see so at this point do you pull
guard yeah okay so
that's when I fell
like he's he's
mentally he's he's not he's worried now
did you try to pull close guard here no
I knew he was going to bring Denny in
okay because that's the defense against
pulling closed guard yeah
but I like that
what do you I like people bringing the
knee between my legs
because see I'm gonna close my guard
even with his legging okay he is he's
he's stopping the CL well this is this
is awkward but because I was holding his
arm that's why he felt he had no hand to
post got it but still it puts a leg in
but you're able to close your guard
around if you're okay with that I do
that really well as three people from
that position a lot what's the sweep I
guess it just pushed okay he's just a
place to your left side yeah okay
because he has no oh it's almost like uh
you mean you're basically around his
back a little bit he knew that like I
swept a lot of people with that sweep so
you you see he kept leaning to his left
to my right yeah so I want to push them
to my left so you see him leaning over
to my right a lot what's the right
answer for him to like roll or something
no I mean he's stuck he does not really
he's stuck there but the one thing he
did he kept off me completely see that
he's leaning yeah true like he's too
afraid of my attack now because he that
you know he should lean on me yeah you
know you should bring the fight to me so
when I fell him you know
like I I knew he was like he's too
worried about my attacks now oh yeah
that's right so he can't yeah he comes
back to the center he has no like so
he's not engaging at that time he's a
hundred percent just defending so I felt
that I'm like he doesn't want to engage
and he's looking I knew at that point he
wants my foot because our first fight I
had this like the same position I wasn't
holding his arm and he went to attack my
foot which he did you know he got into
hold or what okay yeah so I know he's
looking at my foot
which foot sorry the left my right they
have my right foot okay
so I'm hoping he's hiding it I'm holding
his arm and now you're going to the back
as an arm drag type of thing so the
moment that I came off now I'm here I'm
holding his arm so he cannot come up so
he's you know I'm holding his left arm
so he cannot post a hand on the floor
and come up and he's holding it right to
try to get you yeah
basically to prevent you from attacking
yeah
oh that's interesting and he rolls yeah
he tried to he tried to get me off
balance so see now I'm switching I
switched the grip on his arm so I can
free my left arm
can I ask you a question like uh
was there a chance he sweeps you here I
mean there's always a chance but very
bad yeah but see my left arm is free
I'll see you can post yeah
why was your left arm free oh cause
you're using it you got it got it
okay
and now I tried the hook now you will
see
yeah but what I knew his Hispanic
because
he did a move that he completely opened
himself up like I'm holding his left arm
so by holding their arm
his that prevents him from defending the
hook on that side because his arm is
being hauled across so their arm cannot
block the hook and
I mean that's what the [ __ ] with your
left leg Yeah so you see when he come up
but I would say I mean that's my guess
but bushes
he's a big guy you know he's like 110
kilos 112 something like that which is
245 yeah all right yeah so what were you
at the time uh less 220 yeah 220.
a nice slim 100 kilo okay
so
it hits
his defense are not amazing he's good
but you know he's not known to have
amazing defense so by being the big guy
in the room when you train you used to
get out of situation because of your
size you shake people off you know it's
it's because of your size you shake them
off you get off some bad positions you
can I mean I could feel on the first
fight I'm side control you know so he
explode out so you know you I've seen
him doing that a few of his fights no
you're not in the most technical way
just I'm getting out and he did because
of his size
so and he did the same thing like he
tried to stood up when I'm on his back
did he completely open up the hooks he
will see the next move his head gonna
come up and he gonna try to get off the
floor so basically come up shake you off
kind of energy that was no difference
for the hooks I put both hooks in
straight away
his arms yeah I'm off balance yeah see I
didn't bring him up he came up yeah and
now
I'm attacking his neck and he's worried
about the hooks
that's fatal mistake that's like defense
always come first remember what I just
said now the defense first Escape second
so he's not worried more about the
points than his neck
so it was like a a progression of
mistakes that's why I think he did he
got frustrated when he couldn't take me
down and then when I pull God he was he
was frustrated that the fight wasn't
going his way you know he's very good
about taking down he tried over and over
again for five minutes and here he was
frustrated about the hooks so he's like
it's almost like the frustration things
like no no these folks shouldn't be here
like I pull God on the grips that I want
he's not comfortable inside my God he's
not in a position that he wants to be
he's over leaning to his left you know
to to to to not he's not engaging or
trying to pass he's trying to get the
foot but his arm is trapped he's gonna
get nowhere and then when I swapped him
thundered his words start collapsing you
know he couldn't take me down I pull God
I'm swept in he tried to roll me over no
he didn't get me anywhere the first
movement that he tried to escape I'm on
his back I mean now he's lost yeah
that if you just go back to him standing
up
see both hook goes in no defense like
there was nothing up on the way of those
hooks
coming up you're you're high enough on
him to where the weight was just
probably immense
it just felt
too heavy man you got it you already got
you're already you're already going for
the choke of course there's no time to
lose
look at that yeah so you're not like
worried I'm gonna get shaken off you're
going for the trip okay you got your
right hand no shaking you off I'm with
no back now we're in this together and
your your right hand is opening up the
lapel my right hand is holding his arm
sorry yeah like you're holding the
sleeve but holding the sleeve and I'm
already going for the neck
because it's timing at which point do
you let go of the sleeve and open up
help with the power do you not need it
no I did that but first I want to try to
make a grip like then I need to
establish control before I let goes on
got it
so I kept holding that a bit longer and
then when I fell okay I have a good
control over the back then I Let Go
do you
okay so you have like a light grip on
his lapel but you're thinking you know
what I need to adjust that you need to
adjust yeah you're like holding it there
and you're thinking okay at some point I
need to adjust all I need all I want is
to get under his chin then I know it's
it's I mean it's now I can't go for it
because if it's over there's no choke
right I mean the wrist needs to be on
the
that's just not right okay it's not
right or it doesn't work it both it's
not writing doesn't work I mean would
you tap the choke on your chin no just
pressure
have you you heard but it's not going to
choke you out I don't know I don't know
I'm not let me argue this I love this
arguing with Roger great thing about
jokes this is great okay like clock joke
it was always interesting to me because
in Judo it's illegal to have the gear on
them
and face and so it was kind of
liberating for me to be allowed to have
our gear on the face no it's just
liberating no that you don't have to
worry about it like of course it's more
effective to go under the chin but I'm
surprised just because the amount of
pressure like it's all about how much
you can take it you can take a lot but
it feels like no it doesn't feel
comfortable I mean sometimes on your
mouth it cuts your mouth now you're
bleeding you feel horrible no but it
feels that's not the feeling the feeling
it might not be a joke but the feeling
like like it's a pressure that
everything's just closing in but but it
doesn't take you anywhere like you're
not gonna go to sleep you might not go
to sleep so it's just pressure
yes so pressure he hurts is
uncomfortable but it it is not going to
break your face and it's not going to
put you to sleep so if I don't get the
neck I don't go for the kill
I'm like I'm I'm holding the the his
collar you know my my wrist is almost
under it's you know I I'm trying to kind
of dig in if if I can dig in then I'll
adjust the call but first I need to dig
it I dig in first and adjust can you do
all that with one hand or no I did
so you can tighten the choke with just
one hand no I need the second one to
open the level but you're like digging
in with one I'm digging it under the
chin under his under now I need to go
deeper but that the going deeper
requires the second hand he does okay it
does and but that requires you letting
go of the other hand yeah I have to let
go eventually
yeah let's see all right yeah well
that's over yeah because I'm already
under his like the first hand got under
the chin
do you need the a hand on the second
level yeah of course otherwise he turns
and he's out that's the control of the
Turning versus the tightening of the
choke yeah he does both it helps tighten
the collar and stop the person rolling
out
will you
feeling pretty good about this position
yes
I just felt it's getting tighter tighter
tighter tighter because he wasn't super
tight from the beginning it wasn't like
the perfect choke so it was still I mean
I knew it was like it's very close to
the end but you know you I still need to
just those to the risk of maybe escaping
is it possible for his head to slip out
yeah is it possible yes but I'm closing
that Gap
yeah
and here
what does that feel like relief relief
like
awesome amazing
somebody on Reddit ask ask him about the
Cross grip he used to sweep followed
with the genius grips which when
buchesha was inverted did you use a
Cross grip when you sweeped did you I
guess the Cross grip in the arm that
must be oh that's the cross group okay
uh what's the genius behind that or was
that just the uh do you like that kind
of that kind of grip yeah because I
always like close guard and no one wants
to be in anyone's close card right it's
open God is the step to pass
so everybody when you try to close the
guide they bring them in the middle like
if you if if you're not standing if
you're lower on the ground and the open
guard if you're close to me you need
that knee between so it's a must that's
when I start developing the attack you
know I managed to have long legs to
close my legs around people even with
that and then I just developed that
sweep when did you start developing that
like I don't remember when but I would
say before black belt
Okay so
your answer to that is not to figure out
how to prevent them from putting the
knee in
is there an answer to that no
the good guys will always no you're
currently remove that leg out of the way
that's not possible well maybe off
balance them enough to wear this now no
okay I mean you you can try but like
it's hard if you scan off balance that
you'll sweep them
right so that needs gonna see you're
gonna have to say it's not full sleep
yeah
because that's is the is extremely
common to have that I mean I if I'm on
your guard open guard you know if you
have your legs you've found between both
of your legs in the open guard mind you
will be between your legs because it's a
must money cannot be on the floor